los problemas en torno a boris johnson
parecen no terminar en medio de la
lluvia de críticas en su contra por
asistir a una fiesta en downing street
en pleno confinamiento ahora un
legislador conservador acusa a su
gobierno por chantaje
en los últimos días varios diputados se
han enfrentado a presiones e
intimidaciones por parte de miembros del
gobierno tras suponer o expresar su
deseo de presentar un voto de confianza
contra el primer ministro
la intimidación de un miembro del
parlamento es un asunto grave y es que
desde que se filtró la asistencia de
johnson a la fiesta son muchos los
diputados de su propio partido los que
le han dado la espalda presentando
cartas de confianza en su contra que
podrían llegar a destituirlo si se
prueban estas amenazas o intentos de
coacción pasaría a ser asunto de la
justicia acusaciones que johnson niega
he visto evidencias o ha sabido nada
sobre ninguna de esas alegaciones sobre
todo porque estoy centrado en qué
hacemos con el problema número uno de
los británicos que es el cob y 19 a
menchú
hasta ahora johnson se niega a dimitir
tras los escándalos asegurando que
llevara a su partido a las próximas
elecciones previstas para 2024 el primer
ministro ganó los comicios de 2019 con
un amplio respaldo no obstante estas
filtraciones amenazan con hundir su
popularidad en reino unido